bonsoir bienvenue à tous dans ce nouveau
7,8 le débat
innovation le terme est partout dans les
médias dans la bouche de nos politiques
dans celle des industriels même nos
jeunes diplômés inspiré par les success
stories américaine ne rêve que de monter
leur start up et de se distinguer en
brillant entrepreneur les mettre au mot
en matière d'innovation vous les avez
déjà peut être entendu ce sont big data
réalité virtuelle objets connectés
thérapie génique ce sont les industries
de demain alors faut-il traverser
l'atlantique pour innover non la france
se défend particulièrement bien et les
yvelines tirent leur épingle du jeu
trois entrepreneurs sont avec nous ce
soir pour en témoigner alors comment
profiter du moteur local avec nous pour
y répondre rachid benchaïb vous êtes
directeur scientifique de sky
therapeutics une start up qui développe
un nouveau médicament
julien bas essence vous êtes co
fondateur de sky one portal et vous êtes
spécialisé dans la réalité virtuelle
notre plan julien fait ça vous êtes
fondateur de m to m
et votre domaine ce sont l'internet des
objets les objets connectés les capteurs
ce sera super bonsoir à tous les trois
une chair avant d'énumérer vos
différentes inventions données - chacun
votre définition de l'innovation
évidemment et ce qui vous passionne dans
ce secteur rachid ben jawad et comment
je pourrais définir innovation
l'innovation en ce qui me concerne dans
mon secteur c'est le développement
d'outils
nouveaux qui permettraient
d'avancer de façon
importante dans le champ qui est le mien
c'est à dire la thérapeutique médicale à
trouver des solutions
karabatic les solutions thérapeutiques
par le bill développement de produits
d'outils moléculaire pour parler un peu
le jargon scientifique qui puisse
définir une nouvelle génération d'
approche pour les thérapies notamment
les thérapies géniques comme vous l'avez
dit dans l'introduction qui nous
soignerons demain exactement julien mahé
sens mais pour nous c'est un petit peu
différent ce qu'on n'est pas
on est parti sur quelque chose qui est
plus lié sur du divertissement sur
amuser les gens sur leur apporter une
technologie il n'y avait pas auparavant
donc on est vraiment sur le côté
apporter quelque chose de nouveau et de
faire rêver les gens un petit peu et on
va aussi vers notre temps quelque chose
de médical donc l'espère un jour aidé
par la rééducation parle pour moi pas le
rationnement plus tard par des personnes
donc l'innovation c'est pour apporter
quelque chose de gens soient les du
plaisir soit quelque chose qui peut les
aider j'ai bien fait ça à la nouveauté
c'est aussi un as - partager oui tout à
fait l'innovation pour moi c'est
vraiment faire avancer les usages les
services ce qui est compliqué dans
l'innovation c'est pas d'avoir une idée
innovante c'est de la mettre en oeuvre
mais clairement pour moi c'est vraiment
apporter à la société la communauté
quelque chose de plus que ce soit pour
du divertissement pur de la santé ou
bien un service public et on a besoin de
gens comme vous vous parlez de la
société justement ben voilà pour pour
pour avancer pour progresser
vous n'êtes pas sur nos bonnes gens
comme au bénéfice de l'homme mais en
tout cas on a besoin effectivement faire
évoluer les pratiques
les usages notamment si si on fait
référence à notre solution de gestion de
l'éclairage public ce qui est important
c'est d'éclairer au bon endroit au bon
moment je pense que vous avez tous vu un
jour ou l'autre un lampadaire ou un
bâtiment public éclairé en plein jour ça
ça fait pas avancer la société oui on se
dit c'est un gâchis d'énergie
complètement et alors vous justement
passons aux inventions a les idées vous
développer alors quel genre de solution
dans notre nous développons des
solutions qui sont utilisent l'internet
des objets donc des solutions complètes
alors ça veut dire quoi l'internet des
objets ça fait partie des mots comme ça
qu'on lit un peu partout alors
effectivement l'internet des objets on
est submergée de ce mot haiti internet
des objets l'idée c'est réellement
qu'avec les nouvelles technologies qui
sont très récentes
on arrive à tous connectés et en
connectant vraiment où on arrive à gérer
des des solutions complexes et
évidemment ça permette d'abdos petit
musée et d'adapter les usages en ayant
que l'on a des différents objets et par
exemple sur l'éclairage public pour
revenir à votre première application sur
l'éclairage public en fait ça
permettrait de faire ça permet
d'interconnecter les systèmes et de les
rendre interopérables on pourrait
imaginer demain un éclairage public qui
puisse être commandés par des équipes de
secours ou qu'ils puissent se mettre
dans un état
particulier parce que une automobile
connectés ou autonome a lancé un signal
de détresse on peut également considérer
qu' on est vraiment très proche d'être
capable de sur un accident d'être
capable d'illuminer
différemment pour prévenir les autres
usagers il y avait la présence de l'acsi
voilà et est-ce qui est ce qui est
vraiment important de comprendre dans
l'internet des objets c'est que
aujourd'hui on ne dispose on ne sait pas
encore des deux les données dont on va
disposer demain puisque ça évolue
vraiment tous les jours
peut-être que de n'en veut dire quoi on
ne sait pas
les données aujourd'hui on dispose de
données oui et en fait avec l'évolution
d'internet des objets ne sait pas encore
quels seront les données disponibles
demain qui pourront interagir avec nos
systèmes je pense par exemple à la
réalité virtuelle je pense que la
réalité virtuelle va être à la fois
clientes de l'internet des objets
d'objets connectés mais aussi va pouvoir
donner des les informations pour pouvoir
exécuter des travaux si on prend une
application métier
je pense également on sent que ça
s'applique pour les médicaments
à son avons justement rachid benchetouia
donc votre votre innovation on nous on
s'intéresse maladie génétique qui vous
le savez font partie du patrimoine de
chacun il était difficile avant les
années 1980 de dire des familles que
l'enfant qui naissaient était atteint
d'une maladie génétique y avait c'était
une fatalité n'est pas d'eux des
solutions thérapeutiques puisque ça
faisait partie du soin donc on développe
depuis de nombreuses années maintenant
des solutions qui permettent d'acheminer
des gènes puisqu'il sait c'est de ça
qu'il s'agit dans les cas de maladies
génétiques des gènes que l'on construit
de façon artificielle au laboratoire
pour pouvoir les acheminer jusqu'aux
tissu qui n'exprime plus ou expriment
mal les produits des jeunes en question
dans le câble telle ou telle maladie
génétique donc ça c'est ce qu'on appelle
la thérapie génique en est spécialisée
dans notre cas dans la production de ces
outils moléculaires ce que je disais
tout à l'heure qui transportent
ccgn jeunes organisent dans l'organisme
c'est exactement ça la thérapie génique
c'est une voie d'administration qui
relativement récente et fort justement
il existe aujourd'hui une thérapie
génique et commercialise et est ce que
ça existe déjà exactement il y a le
premier
médicament thérapeutique qui sous forme
d'un virus modifiés qui a été
commercialisé en 2012 qui porte le nom
de libération pas faire de publicité
pour pour les procure la société la
concurrents mais c'est cette année
alors ça ça prête ça s'attrape par
excusez moi la ld elle qui est une lit
pas une pour une déficience dans la
lipoprotéine lipase c'est une déficience
qui conduit à des
dépôts créatique des programmes et de
pardon qui complique donc là l'existence
des
exactement
voilà existait déjà un premier
médicament c'est un espoir parce qu'en
plus la délivrance de l'autorisation de
mise sur le marché a été donnée par
l'europe ce qui est assez surprenant
puisqu'on sait que les règles sont
beaucoup plus drastiques en europe
qu'aux états unis par exemple ou au
japon en asie et donc c'est un grand
espoir qui est soulevée là parce que
quand on regarde l'origine de la
thérapie génique 1 qui date je voulais
10 de la fin des années 80 e finalement
la période qui a ac kaka ac a
donné qu'elle nécessité tout le
développement pour essayer de faire en
sorte que ces thérapies puisse appliquer
à l'homme est relativement courte en
réalité mais il y a eu énormément de 2,2
de travail moléculaire de compréhension
fondamentale dans la biologie et dans
les mécanismes d'un mécanistiques qui
ont fait que effectivement aujourd'hui
les produits sont beaucoup plus sur un
point de vue de la de la santé et des
patients et de 30 ans 40 ans quand même
hein depuis les années 80 effectivement
défaut pour que voilà une telle
innovation exactement quand on saigne le
marché voilà quand on sait que le
médicament générique chimiques mais dix
ans de développement pharmaceutique qui
coûte à peu près un milliard d'euros là
il s'agit de nouveaux types de
médicaments qui sont des virus qui
transportent des gènes médicaments donc
en plus de de l'idée initiale il fallait
le développement il fallait la sécurité
il fallait énormément d'étapes
supplémentaires par rapport à une
molécule chimique pour la valider les
acquis donc ça donne un espoir énorme
pour la suite des opérations et ça donne
une idée quand même du temps qu'il faut
c'est vrai que c'est une bonne nouvelle
à la fin mais ça a nécessité des années
est en tout cas pour c'est une
pathologie là pour lesquels on n'avait
aucun traitement avant voilà aujourd'hui
votre idéal de scientifiques c'est que
dans dix ans il y au moins plusieurs
attaques au j adore mon origine
génétique qui soit qu'ils soient gays il
ya plusieurs phases cliniques de niveau
3 qui sont aujourd'hui mises en place
dans le monde pour énormément de
pathologie génétique donc finalement
moins de dix ans peut-être moins de 10
ans s'attend à ce qu'il explosion
d'essai clinique est de mise sur le
marché dans les années à venir dans ce
secteur là julien b sens on va dans un
tout autre domaine
on revient du côté de la réalité
virtuelle vous quel est votre votre
innovation alors on fait notre
innovation c'est de faire les rites et
virtuels c'est un mot qu'on commence à
connaître un petit peu partout dans mon
public ses passages à vide les races aux
jeux vidéo et aux casques surtout les
casques de réalité virtuelle qui ont été
sortis par 13 avant de se racheter par
facebook ça débarque donc forcément fait
connaître les choses et non propose une
solution un peu différente qui ne
l'utilisent pas de casque qui est juste
une paire de lunettes de cinéma et qui
projette l'image sur les murs
effectivement
voir un film en exactement sur les mêmes
on projette pas sur tous les murs donc
on peut pas se retourner mais par contre
on est une expérience immersive à se
cantonner ce que les gens arrivent ils
mettaient lunettes et il joue où ils
font tout autre chose on a plusieurs
types d'applications donc c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui change la façon
d'utiliser la technologie qu'on a des
expériences assez similaires mais on
appréhende différemment et du coup on
peut l'utiliser à d'autres usages alors
justement de deux principaux usages
on est parti de l'industrie parce que
c'est de là qu'on venait c'est là on a
travaillé donc c'était notre premier
client donc ils vont utiliser ça pour
afficher des maquettes numériques par
exemple de véhicules de bâtiments et
après on a commencé à faire du
divertissement 2
une borne d'arcade pour les salles de
jeu plutôt à l'international mais ça
commence à redevenir
un nouveau marché en france et de ça on
a défini qu'on pouvait utiliser nos jeux
en plus pour du médical c'est un peu le
nouveau thème de cette année c'est ont
été contactés par l'hôpital de garches
premier donc pour faire d'autre avec des
patients pour faire de la rééducation ça
veut dire que en fait mon jeu font que
bouge beaucoup ce qu'on est devant un
écran de 3 mètres donc on va se déplacer
de gauche à droite en arrière ça devait
se lever c'est un petit peu comme la wii
non c'est un petit peu comme la wii la
vie plus poussée
dans ses rangs une expérience où on
rentre dans le jeu et de ce fait sont
procurés une expérience fun de quelques
minutes pour les gens soient là on peut
les amener dans les expériences
forcément beaucoup plus cool pour les
patients beaucoup plus tranquille mais
qui vont les mettre dans un contexte de
jeu et s'amuser et ce qui fait qu'ils
vont pouvoir se dépasser et qui on en a
eu on a fait deux ou trois séances de
test et on s'est rendu compte que assez
facilement il allait faire des
mouvements qui ne faisait plus et que si
on leur a demandé de faire une machine
parle en prison avait dit mme granger
mal j'arrête alors que là ils ont fait
naturellement donc on est vraiment parti
quelque chose de très industriel très
carré pour faire du jeu pour maintenant
aller vers
du médical les applications très variées
pour ses systèmes alors ce qu'il faut
dire c'est que vous venez d'un grand
groupe on est devant nous de renan vous
également vers le d'airbus et c'est un
peu la spécificité de ce territoire
c'est que on a ces grands groupes qui se
suicide un petit peu ces vocations
entrepreneuriales
allez-y dites nous comment vous avez
commencé alors tout simplement airbus a
une filiale qui qui s'appelle airbus
groupe développement et qui passent des
conventions d'essaimage avec des
employés d'airbus pour des des projets
dans lesquelles airbus croit il n'y a
aucune prise de contrôle c'est
uniquement un un lien
contractuels et
c'est à dire nous de développer l'emploi
notre contrepartie c'est de développer
l'emploi et airbus s'engage à mettre les
moyens et pas forcément pécunier aussi
d'ouverture de réseau
pour que le projet aboutisse donc c'est
aussi simple que cela et c'est très
efficace puisque quand on est une petite
société comme la nôtre vous imaginez
bien que aller taper à la porte de la dp
par exemple on pas des paris
c'est juste pas possible parce qu'on est
trop petit donc il entendait même pas le
note sur la porte donc quand on vient à
dos et à airbus évidemment on a on a
quelqu'un avec nous qui pèse et par
conséquent vous ouvre la porte alors
après ça prend ça prend pas ça c c'est
bien évidemment à la mesure de votre
performance mais ça ça ouvre des portes
est normale chez penguin de votre côté
alors vous c'est un peu particulier
c'est une science qui vient de
l'université qui vient du cnrs si je me
trompe exactement de l'inserm de
l'université vers seuil d'une unité qui
avait été créée donc il ya quatre ans de
cela on le sait notre savoir-faire qui a
été valorisé la recherche publique
française qui a été valorisé rappelons
le est exactement celle sur nrj c'est
exactement ce sont des fruits de notre
savoir faire aussi un chacun une
histoire d'un autre était dédié
justement à l'émergence de produits donc
mais 10 mai de médicaments de nouvelle
génération et ce savoir faire là
on s'est rendu compte qu'on pouvait le
valoriser
et donc il ya deux ans on a créé une
émanation ce qu'on a une spin-off de
l'unité de recherche dans laquelle nous
étions donc
j'en ai pris la direction et quatre à
cinq personnes de l'unité ont été
embauchés sous forme de contrats à durée
indéterminée pour travailler au sein de
cette nouvelle société qui restent
hébergés avec des contrats cadres au
sein de les locaux de l'université de
versailles saint quentin vous avez déjà
créé de l'emploi ça c'est un point
important quand exactement aujourd'hui
vraiment on en a créé un peu plus
puisqu'on est un groupe de 10 personnes
ou qui personnes tous ans en contrat à
durée déterminée on embauche et même de
perdre des personnes extérieures au
groupe d'origine et ça ça crée
effectivement de l'emploi d'adp leur
richesse supplémentaire et puis ça
augmente un peu notre portefeuille aussi
en termes de 2,2 de produits et de
valorisation ce qui est extrêmement
important l'effort qui a été fait ces
dernières années est extrêmement
important non juste pour dire une chose
intéressante c'est que les investisseurs
qui sont à l'origine donc de la création
de cette start-up skalli thérapeutique
ce sont des associations de familles
essentiellement donc on n'a pas de
business angels devant les enfants sont
atteints dans les anglais sont atteints
de pathologies génétiques ce qui fait
que effectivement ça donne une dimension
supplémentaire à la recherche que
que l'on fait enceinte de ces startups
parce qu'on est confronté finalement un
peu à la réalité
de la maladie au jour le jour donc c'est
une certaine un peu particulière je
l'avouer aujourd'hui l'idée est de
pouvoir donc valoriser cette recherche
sous forme d'un nouveau médicament qui
porterait ses fruits qui auraient des
preuves de principe importante et qu'on
souhaiterait ensuite revendre la licence
à des groupes pharmaceutiques dont c'est
le travail d'amener le produit jusqu'à
jusqu'à 500 kg puisque ça coûte cher on
le sait ce n'est pas à la borat war une
start-up lama laboratoires académiques
qui peut se targuer de pouvoir emmener
jusqu'à clinique autorise ce moment sur
le marché des produits de ce genre je
viens bas et sens de votre côté et donc
s'en sortait de renault c'est encore une
petite histoire un peu différente mais
c'est vrai que c'est l'occasion de voir
aussi de la start up c'est autre chose
que
c'est peut-être trois personnes qui se
rend compte un powerpoint on part à
l'aventuré aux états unis je ne sais pas
non il ya plein de profils différents
il ya plein de profils différents qui
peuvent amener un extrait une société
nous c'est juste rencontré chez renault
rno n'a pas été une aide entre
guillemets
sauf que je finalement ça reste un
client de garder de bonnes relations
avec eux donc ça permet de se garer
voilà et c'est exactement ça permet
d'avoir quand même un client déjà un
premier ce qu'on a commencé sans
investissement on ajuste véhicule nos
ventes on se faisait un premier client
qui nous en amener d'autres qu'on avait
nos contextes car là vous n'avez pas
besoin d'investisseurs pour le moment
d'accord le moment donc nous sommes ont
fait place au total trois associés donc
rencontré chez renault donc olivier
manuel et deux autres cofondateurs et on
est parti comme ça en faisant nos
premières ventes et en enchaînant aux
montants petit à petit en profitant bien
sûr de quelques aides de la région tels
le prêt d'honneur qui en général la
première étape de la région et puis
après on est arrivé jusqu'à des projets
comme futur en seine et cap digital et
la région ile de france où ils ont
financé la moitié d'un projet donc donc
a permis de développer notre système
pour du fitness par exemple donc état
intermédiaire entre le jeu médical mais
qui a été financé à moitié par la région
et aujourd'hui vous êtes hébergés à
prendre et on est hébergée à prendre un
vol donc sur la région de 55 sur
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines donc c'est un endroit où on est
maintenant depuis deux ans à peu près ça
se passe très bien ça permet de
rencontrer aussi beaucoup de monde lala
l'agglomération il est très active
on a l'occasion aussi de participer
matthieu comité de sélection a sky cube
pour sélectionner des start up et suivre
leur avancement donc c'est pas encore
croisé avec julien ici mais c'est aussi
notre expérience vont se retrouver de
l'autre côté de voir les autres pitch
est présenté et c est ça nous permet
nous aussi progressé parce qu'on fait
beaucoup d'erreurs au quotidien et on
apprend tous les jours et sa culture est
de votre côté donc vous êtes un cube et
à ce calcul donc on a été sélectionné en
novembre 2016 puis nous sommes rentrés
fin janvier en incubation donc les
bénéfices on va les bénéfices il est il
est énorme et il est colossal puisque en
fait on a on a vraiment un
accompagnement vraiment personnalisé
donc est vraiment propre au projet qu'on
veut développer on est cette start up
actuellement on a tous dépassé différent
des projets à des niveaux de maturité
qui sont complètement différents et la
fox réellement de ce qu'on a pu trouver
chez sky tubes et aussi à travers
incuballiance le partenaire
de castries s'est réellement qu'ils
s'adaptent à notre niveau de maturité
donc on a pu par exemple je vous parlais
tout à l'heure de notre système de
gestion de l'éclairage public
c'est un système dans lequel ils croient
mais ils nous ont permis d'ouvrir les
yeux sur les échéances réaliste le
marché réel et
force est de constater que pourra pas
tenir et
la distance à cause de ce cycle de vente
qui sont vraiment très élevés ceux des
administrations publiques
administrations publiques appel d'offres
néanmoins on est né aidez nous à les
trouver une nouvelle application et on a
on a cherché effectivement d'autres
vecteurs
d'autres relais de croissance étant
donné qu'on est fournisseur de
connectivité de cartes sim
qui travaille entre machines mais on
s'est posé la question de savoir quelles
étaient les vecteurs possible pour cette
connectivité et on a trouvé que
aujourd'hui d'après les études de marché
les études qu'on a fait en complément on
a vraiment un créneau sur le traceur gps
qui est en pleine explosion on en voit
on envoie un petit peu de traceurs qu'on
insère dans un objet alors par exemple
nous on a
on a décidé d'aller sur une niche
d'applications mais qui reste quand même
un marché mondial il a filé c'est la
sécurisation des fusils de chasse donc
aujourd'hui on commence avec un simple
antivol qui vous permet à la fois de le
mettre sous surveillance et de le
géolocaliser lorsqu'ils se déplacent ça
peut aussi avoir un attrait pour le
chasseur de revoir son parcours mais
vraiment le nez sur le créneau de la
sécurité et puis in fine et on va
développer cette solution et on
atteindra c'est certain des niveau de
technicité qui nous permettront de
désactiver une arme en fonction d'un
distro critères voilà
pour on arrive bientôt à la fin de cette
émission
chacun qu'est-ce que vous conseiller aux
entrepreneurs qui souhaitent se lancer
et une difficulté enfin quelque chose
qui a été difficile pour vous racheter
fadjri alors j'ai pas eu l'occasion -
effectivement comme julien c'est julien
passé par un incubateur vous auriez
répond c'est vrai mais on était dans un
processus de maturation déjà bien avancé
et du coup on n'a pas eu effectivement
la chance je peux pas de chance parce
qu'on aurait peut-être effectivement pu
évoluer d'une façon un peu différente
mais
l'expérience qui la montre c'est à dire
cette émanation de l'ufr des soldats
santé aujourd'hui
avec le contexte dans lequel nous sommes
sains de lui faire c'est à dire des
recherches fondamentales liées aux
maladies génétiques également nous
permettent des échanges constructifs
pour avancer faire des modifications qui
permettent aux produits d'évoluer et de
pouvoir rentrer dans les critères de
sélection pour aller vers la clinique la
difficulté quelles difficultés on a pu
rencontrer au cours de notre
de nos deux ans de création aujourd'hui
je pense qu'elle était
lié évidemment au risque que les
molécules développées ne puisse pas
donné satisfaction en terrible que ça ne
marche pas exactement c'est toujours le
risque
qik est inhérent à l'entrepreneur l'iran
exactement entrepreneurs mais on était
assez confiants sur l'aspect
technologique l'aspect production qui
n'ont de savoir-faire le notre coeur de
métier et du coup là c'était uniquement
et bien les différents produits
développés est ce que l'un d'entre eux
va pouvoir rentrer dans nos critères et
être donc admis à aller vers l'air avec
une du post est un peu la difficulté
inhérente effectivement entrepreneurs je
viens là et sens de votre côté des
choses déjà ses gammes de s'imaginer que
ça va pas être simple c'est quand même
une expérience qui est très
enrichissante très intéressante mais
faut vraiment se donner à 100% quand on
songera de projets en même temps ça même
quand ça se passe bien c'est n'est
jamais simple et toujours des problèmes
nature des embûches mais ça vaut le coup
et surtout de trouver un montant bien un
bon équilibre entre croire en son projet
et écouter les autres il ya énormément
de choses qui vont se passer autour de
vous il ya des invitations peu partout
des séminaires des événements on va vous
dire plein de choses le vrai le faux le
court le contrer il faut pas s'enfermer
sur soi en disant j'ai raison j'ai gagné
ça va marcher il faut pas non plus
croire tout ce qu'on dit il faut réussir
à trouver le bon timing
exactement donc il faut arriver à
écouter mais aussi savoir croire en son
projet et ses idées et à rester
convaincu dans sa trajectoire comme tu
fais ton chien fait ça moi je suis
parfaitement d'accord avec julien il
faut il faut être vigilant par contre je
pense qu'on est rentré dans une époque
où
et on peut le voir notamment sur le
territoire de saint quentin il ya
énormément de soutien je parlerai pas
des de l'aide pour moi ça est à une
sonorité relative et geraghty il ya
vraiment du soutien parce que au final
c'est vous qui allez prendre les
décisions ça sera à vous de les
appliquer parce que de toute façon ça
sera à vous de les assumer néanmoins il
y aura
vraiment beaucoup de soutien et de gens
expérimentés qui vous amèneront à
réfléchir et vous amener à réfléchir
c'est vraiment une grande richesse parce
que parce qu'au final
quand on est pardonnez moi l'expression
la tête dans le guidon
on a du mal à prendre du recul et quand
on sait qu'on a des voix bienveillante
autour de soi qui apporte un regard
critique et apporte un regard critique
mais constructif on a tout intérêt à les
entendre à réfléchir à ce qu'ils disent
est derrière à en discuter avec eux
suite à notre réflexion donc je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on a vraiment la chance
d'être dans une ère où l'innovation les
start up c'est quelque chose qui est
maintenant bien compris et pour lesquels
il ya des structures qui sont en place
merci très rapidement chacun quand ça va
atterrir votre innovation sur le marché
rachid benchaïb on l'espère dans douze
ans dans deux en super g déjà vendu des
produits disponibles et on espère aller
vers nouveaux projets comme le médical
et prochaine ou l'année suivante oui et
j'ai bien fait ça pour rien que pour
l'éclairage public la solution est prête
on attend que le territoire de saint
quentin nous attribue un mini projets
pour expérimenter et on livre nos
premiers antivol pour fusils en décembre
donc finalement c'est le nom de demain
mais en même temps c'est très proche là
on est dans quelques mois quelques
années ça va vite
merci à tous les trois d'avoir participé
à cette émission et joue on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
c'est tout le débat très bonne soirée à
vous
[Musique]